we are starting the new year with a new
restaurant at la rea which is located in
the panorama towers and here to tell us
all about it is executive chef shawn
o'neal good to see you buddy good to see
you man thank you so much for having me
thanks for being here how would you
describe like the vibe of the restaurant
the feel of the restaurant um i like to
say kind of new york chic la cool and
vegas attitude oh i love it man i love
it we're bringing sexy to vegas we
really kind of are want to develop kind
of that strip feel but off strip local
welcoming everybody bring your friends
bring your family bring the kids we want
everybody that sounds like my kind of
place yeah and you brought some of the
food let's talk about some of the menu
items we got here so we're trying to
source as much stuff as we can locally
so we're working with a ranch in
northern nevada that we're getting all
our wagyu beef wow okay beef in the
desert i want to try that yeah we're
working with a little lady in boulder
city she's got all kinds of herbs and
greens for us we've got a little lady in
boulder city that's getting picked into
our herds man yeah it's awesome so we're
keeping it local like i said we want to
keep the vibe local but here we've got
our beautiful amberjack crudo with a
great citrusy base wow this is our
number one seller it's a bone marrow
right it's a little caveman-ish but
people are eating it up it's it's flying
out the kitchen let's talk about this
bone marrow because i've heard of people
eating the bone marrow is there like
extra nutrition value or it's just that
it is i mean bone marrow is high in all
kinds of vitamins all kinds of proteins
um and it's really one of those things
that kind of have we've been eating
since caveman days that's why i call it
caveman we've been eating there forever
then we've got a beautiful dessert this
is our sticky toffee banana bread so
good come on and then this is one of our
features also here this is our pork two
ways so this is a kerbota pork chop our
kubota pork tenderloin and a kurbota um
pork belly that we uh braised and then
we we fried it up real quick and then
we're going to add some of these
beautiful little onion tweels here now
how did you come up with something like
this
and if you don't know sean one master
chef gordon ramsay yeah how did you come
up with this whole what are we doing
here oh yeah so we'll get to the
holidays within a second and the how to
came up with everything is really trying
to give people new experiences right and
this is one of them what's this uh
contraption here what are we lighting
here on las vegas this is a smoking
machine if my lighter will work oh no of
course live on air the lighter doesn't
want to work um so this is a smoking
machine and what we do is we basically
when it works we get it roll in here and
we um we smoke under the clothes here
but i not
[Music]
sous chef packed available pack this a
little too tight this is the cooking
segment what do you do yeah i know all
right so anyway but what would i smell
this smoke yeah
the apple would so this close will fill
up you can see a little bit of smoke
there we go it's starting to come in
there a little bit but what will happen
is this will fill up the entire cloche
and we'll come out and present it so
you're blind you don't know what's going
to be coming to the table until you get
that close lifted off of the top of the
plate so then this plate will be covered
with smoke yep covered with smoke you
can see a little bit of it up in there
so good it smells great it really kind
of gives you that a little bit of
campfire a little bit of outdoorsiness
it but really kind of brings the the
flavors all together right so here we go
we'll turn that guy off we didn't get a
big reveal we didn't get as much smoke
in there as we would at the restaurant
we we overloaded this just a little bit
and then we would serve this and we
would just kind of smoke it
pop it up and down
this beautiful dish does that smoke add
more to the flavor it does so we've got
an apple glaze on here we've got a
little bit apple cider juice is the
sauce so we reduce down some apple cider
some alcoholic apple cider some regular
apple cider and it gives us this super
thick luscious sauce and then the
applewood smoke just adds layers on top
of that so it's you know food is about
building layers building those flavors
up and up and up and this dish right
here is packed full of it sean we can go
an entire hour with you i'm going to
wrap it up here thank you because next
time
we have to talk about the drinks great
drinks great drink man you come down to
the restaurant please come see us we are
excited to be here in vegas
real quick the website
www.loreallosvegas.com thank you sean